bonsoir paris bonsoir le septième art
sa plastique de rêve en électrices plus
d'un
de ci de là refusent même d un ou dix
ans un la voilà qu'elle est belle c'est
incroyable je la voyais plus grande à
quelle heure on manche
elle s'élance vers antoine sa démarche
chaloupée fait gonfler une vague de
désir à travers la salle antoine
lahesalu modestement allant jusqu'à se
prosterner à ces pierres elle retourne à
son pupitre et tout le la scène telle
une déesse
elle semble voler
maîtrise totale à présent elle s'apprête
à faire la roue qui l'a rendu célèbre au
combat comprends pas moi-même l'amour
namouh s'apprête à faire l'amour qui l'a
rendue célèbre